how do you justify that is there an
opportunity to appeal to Future
technology as in the case of Galileo and
aristarchist future eventually
technology caught up and proved them
right do you think the same thing will
happen with string theory and if not why
should we study it if there were no
methods we would check our ideas then I
would have abandoned doing String Theory
before exactly that reason however due
to the interesting interconnection of
different ideas in high energy
theoretical physics you can actually
check ideas theoretically so you can
check the validity of an idea from a
different perspective and come to a
conclusion that idea is correct or false
without experimentations of course that
would validity is the idea itself as
being self-consistent logically correct
mathematically consistent whether or not
that's part of the explanation of our
current Universe we still have to wait
thank you